the thing with spies with all their
secrets and power and egos is that it
really seems to go to their heads and
honestly how can you blame them they are
literally beyond public scrutiny anyone
tries to stick their nose in you just
stamp everything that's classified and
loudly denounced them as unpatriotic
well I see it as a very very serious and
outrageous move on the part of mr. Trump
once again trampling upon the statutory
authorities of the Director of National
Intelligence and the heads of the
independent intelligence agencies
how dare Trump what true American would
ever question why they're being
wiretapped and spied upon good thing
America has MSNBC true patriots hired
mr. Brennand full time so he can vent
his frustrations for everyone to hear of
course to do that MSNBC had to sacrifice
their principles and integrity
President Obama said today he still
stands by his CIA chief John Brennan
even though it turns out the CIA was
indeed spying on the Senate and some
senators are calling for Brennan to be
fired now just to be clear that was in
2014 when they weren't on the same side
and spying on everyone your own elected
leaders included was considered dubious
this is 2019 and the word spying is now
considered politically incorrect it
offends people whose people who secretly
eavesdrop and record and film everyone
agents the good guys a talking point
from the president and those around him
telling Congress spying did occur on the
Trump campaign it's a loaded word has to
know the implications of using that word
and is now Donald Trump's favorite new
word and the Trump media's favorite new
word
Senate Intelligence Chair Dianne
Feinstein accused Brennen CIA of
secretly tracking the Senate's
investigation into one of the worst
abuses in recent CIA history and now
factored in this huge new scandal the
fact that Brennan's CIA was spying on
members of Congress the CIA was spying
on the Senate Intelligence Committee
basically busting into their computers
but I give MSNBC too much credit there
are others too Washington Post gave
Brennan his own column where he
publishes pieces with noble noble titles
I will speak out until integrity returns
to the White House he promises well done
Washington Post it takes courage to set
aside what you believe in to go back on
your word but again it's been five years
who remembers things like that right The
Guardian same thing why is Donald Trump
attacking the US intelligence community
CIA director John Brennan lied to you
and to the Senate fire him
surprisingly Brennan isn't working for
the Guardian
yet one by one though the pundits and
anchors are seeing wrong from right the
question is are they going to demand
Brennan's resignation or accountability
within the CIA patriotic answer by the
way is no holding the CIA accountable
would be stupid secret agents do top
secret stuff and drink martinis and hack
things and carry out special secret
missions DNI I didn't see anything
improper or unlawful and yes James
clapper Brennan's former boss is now a
CNN employee I'll tell you this every
true American can be proud but there are
brave brave people watch over you and
record everything you do was say day and
night whether you want it or not and if
times or politics change in five years
no one will remember it ever happened
you